cumulative frequency now let's think
about where we are in this topic we know
what frequency means right
how frequently how how much how many an
event score occurs within a data set
right now this were cumulative at the
front means we're not just going to
count how many individually there are
per score we're also going to include
the accumulation of all the previous
scores as well
okay hence cumulative now we're going to
use this as an example and to put it
really bluntly for you why do we need to
care about cumulative frequency there's
a lot of reasons but it seems timely to
say to all of you guys one of the very
many reasons is a tie I'm not gonna
explain that yet I'm just gonna let it
sit there for a little while
and see if you can tell me when it
clicks who you're looking for
reminder yeah okay thank you much all
right so we will come back to that that
pointer later and if any of you work out
at what point you're like oh now I know
why you said that Abby let me know if
not I'll tell you at the end to get to
there let's start with this set of data
now it says the frequency table below
shows the marks achieved by a bunch of
students on a particular exam now the
thing I want to focus on unsurprisingly
in this table is the cumulative
frequency which we need to fill in okay
so you've got these classes over there
on the left-hand side I'm gonna start to
drop them down and the first thing I'm
going to ask is why do you think we
sometimes gather data in two classes
what is the point of having a bracket
like 32 39 42 49
and so on sorry want to give a first
suggestion
166 tear and you arrange everything
perfect okay very good so if you didn't
quite catch that and maybe similar up
here well had I do you have a different
reason or a similar one yeah yeah yeah
these are these are both the same kind
of thing right so do remember we said
before we were comparing measures of
central tendency the three of which were
they all started with M mean mode
meaning very good and we said you know
they all have pros and cons one of the
big disadvantages of say the mode the
most common one is and the example I
gave a few of you was in this class what
is the modal height of a person in this
class and there's likely to be no modal
height because everyone's like off by a
half a centimeter or something like that
so there's no height 178 centimeters for
example which is my height where there's
multiple people right so we would group
them and then we take off from from 170
to 175 there's a group from 176 to 180
there's another group and then clearly
one of those might stand out okay how
many of I got am I missing one more ok
very good by the way I'm buying time for
you to put this into your own book also
okay well yeah yes
well pointed out it is supposed to say
80 to 89 so here are the scores that
we've got gonna skip over class Center
just for now and then we've got a
frequency okay are you on the right spot
you try to find it where you are yeah
this is exercise to question five yeah
that's a typo
that's a typo just to see if you're
awake which you obviously are um kids
someone help me out because I'm just not
gonna keep going back to that what are
the frequencies listed for each one
what's the top one parent yep three six
twelve not not fifteen eighteen ten I
thought I heard a nine anyway nevermind
okay so that's fine we've got our
frequencies there so you could
immediately tell me for example what's
the mode
the mode in this case is what we call a
modal class because these are all
classes right the modes are single value
the modes of single value so I could get
the class center and that would be
different against so I'd love you all to
label with me that's the first thing you
can add on to your table here 7279
we don't just call it the mode the modes
a single score we call this guy the
modal class there we go okay so very
good label that on that's important and
then this final column that we're really
interested in and we're gonna actually
start drawing together if you don't have
a ruler
it'll be really useful to have one I
know at least Tyler's going it's
cumulative frequency cumulative
frequency so like I said what this
includes is the frequency of that class
or that score including all of the
previous ones okay so it's pretty easy
to start the top there are no previous
classes for this first one so it's just
through when you go to the next class
down forty to forty nine you include the
six that are in forty to forty nine and
all the previous ones so what will the
cumulative frequency be good well maybe
that's what you're calculating okay and
then you take that number and it
accumulates according to the new it so
it's going to 21 then 36 54 64 fantastic
okay very good
now we're gonna use this in a second
we're gonna put it onto a graph you can
see that this excuse me is 64 down the
bottom is is handy in and off itself
because this is the total group of
people right this is N equals 64 okay
it's worth pointing out and another
color for this one since N equals 64
I'll put it I'll put it here if this is
the number of scores there this is an
appropriate time to remind you all
because we didn't really talk about it
yesterday you can go straight from N
equals 64 to immediately work out what
the meeting is or I should say where the
median is and we know if there's a small
set of data we could just do the
crossing off thing right get it in order
but there's a way we can go straight
from this immediately to where the
meeting is to our what you thinking
n plus 1/2 that'll be the position of
the medium okay in this case M plus 1 is
65 you divide that by 2 gives you 32 and
1/2 which means between the 32nd and the
33rd scores whatever that is
that'll be your medium okay if of course
you had an odd number here and the one I
gave you before was five I think suppose
you had N equals five model n plus one B
in this case 6 so 6 divided by 2 will
give you score number three which is the
bang-on in the middle okay so this tells
us all right the median is going to be
between 32 and 33 where is that on here
you sort of got to keep on counting
right now it looks to me like it's going
to be somewhere in here but which one is
it is it gonna be in this mother is it
going to be in this one mmm now to be
sure some of you have some good
intuition for this some of you not quite
so confident we're going to remember a
really helpful tool here called a
cumulative frequency polygon that's a
bit of a mouthful
cumulative frequency polygon so there is
a short and weird name for it the
cumulative frequency polygon we call it
we call it an oh guys I hope you've seen
that word before even if you have no
memory of what it is we're going to do
one of these together so what I'd love
you to do is and please please use a
ruler for this because the accuracy
actually really matters in fact I'm
gonna go and - - and room nearby and get
a ruler myself all right now you've got
your roll of there before we put pens of
paper let's think about our axes right
what we're going to be graphing is going
to be the classes these scores over here
as compared to our cumulative frequency
because it's a cumulative frequency
polygon that we're going to draw so
across the bottom which is going to be
scores we're gonna have to range from 30
that's our lowest score all the way up
to 89 or 90 will do it in tens right so
that's going to be across the bottom you
can start to think about how wide that
should be in terms of the height of this
thing
what's the lowest value the lowest value
well the lowest number number I've
written here is three but I think this
course actually start from zero right we
start from the bottom and then we count
it up I'm gonna go from zero all the way
down to or up to 64 I'm just going to
make it round and go up to 70 okay so go
ahead use your grid carefully because as
it turns out in many parts of like
graphing things the exact like details
and precision is not that important like
where exactly is the stationary point
it's okay if it's rough but for this
we're actually going to use the
precision of your cumulative frequency
polygon to actually do calculations so
please use your ruler carefully let me
give you some time to do that I have to
do it as well maybe two or three minutes
and then we'll have a graph we're ready
to put onto here okay